so
today uh the the plan is to cover
bias variance trade-off and the role
played by regularization
and the role played by the hypothesis
class
in bias variance trade off so
in last class we spoke about the
concepts of
bias and variance and we probably
briefly mentioned that there is a
trade-off between the two some kind of a
trade-off and today we will see
two two kind of more concrete ways
of how this trade-off comes into picture
in practice
and the second part the role played by
the
hypothesis class is actually you know if
you're interested in machine learning
research it forms a good
entry point into statistical learning
theory
however the the kind of
the the big picture that we want to take
away at the end of the class
is probably uh extremely important if
you want to be a machine learning
practitioner right so
um in order to build a good predictive
models
it's very important that you understand
the role of bias and variance and how
you how you uh
handle the two uh the the two evils so
to speak uh
both bias and variants are bad and you
know how do you balance between the two
that's at the heart of
you know successfully building good
machine learning models in practice
so even though some of it is theoretical
there are
very good take away messages even if you
want to just apply machine learning in
practice
before we go into today's topics a quick
recap of
what we covered in the last lecture or
at least the parts that we covered in
the last lecture that are relevant for
today
so we saw the concept of bias and
variance in classical statistics
classical statistics we are interested
in constructing an estimator for our
parameter theta
and that um the estimator that we
construct
we call it theta hat n where n is the
number of examples that were used in
your you know training set so to speak
and what we saw was theta hat n
is a random variable because it depends
on
ah the noise in the data that was
sampled from from which the model was
fit
and it has because it's a random
variable it has an associated
probability distribution
and that distribution is called the
sampling distribution
and the bias and variance are directly
related to the sampling distribution
of this estimator of theta hat n right
so the centered mean of
of uh of the sampling distribution or
the centered first moment is called the
bias
and the the variance or the covariance
of the estimator is called the variance
right and supposing um in in the
parameter space
theta theta star which is indicated by
this
uh by this black square was the true
parameter
from which data has been being generated
in the world and we collect a sample of
size n a random sample of size n
and we run it through our estimator and
we get an estimate a point estimate for
theta
and supposing we plot it and we repeat
that over and over where we are
resampling data from the true data
generating distribution though in
practice that is hard
but as a mental model imagine you are
gathering a new set of data you collect
new data
and you run it through your estimator
you get another point estimate you plot
it and you will see
that they end up being samples from the
sampling distribution
right and and this the the sampling
distribution will be centered around
some point
here ah calling it ah indicating it by a
triangle
and this is the mean of the
sampling distribution and this gap
is called the bias of the estimator
right and
the variance of the estimator is how
wide the sampling distribution
how what's the variance in the sampling
distribution that's the the variance of
the sampling
of the estimator
there are very uh there's a closely
concept uh
closely related concept of bias and
variance in prediction problems
in machine learning over here we are
interested in prediction
uh whereas over here we are in
interested in statistical inference over
the parameters
here we are interested in making
predictions on unseen data
right and over here
similarly let us this is the
the x and this is y
and we get samples x y from from um
from the data generating distribution
now supposing the true relation between
x y
which we uh define as y expectation of y
given x
is this dotted line so this dotted line
over here
is f equals
expectation of y given x
and because of this definition we get y
equals f of x plus epsilon
where epsilon is some zero mean noise
and here what we see is
though this is the true function we take
some training data of size
n and construct an estimator we call it
f hat n and using f hat n
we make a prediction on a new test
example x star
right and the prediction
may be anywhere on this line in gen in
principle it could be anywhere
the value of of f hat n of x star could
be anywhere
and what we see is if we just like
before
repeat this sampling process where we
collect a new set of n examples
construct a new model using the new set
and make a prediction
on the same x star using the new
estimator it's going to be
a different prediction and the set of
all those predictions
is going to follow some distribution so
the distribution
that is having a thick line is something
similar
to this distribution except it's in the
in the prediction setting right and
again this distribution
has a mean which you know just like
before i am using
a triangle to indicate the indicate the
mean of
of the f hat n
and this ah this this triangle
can in general not be equal to the
the point at which the true function
makes ah its prediction
right and this difference
is called the bias
of f hat n just the way
this difference was the bias of the
theta hat estimator
this difference between the square and
the triangle is the
bias of bias of
f hat n it is the the gap between f hat
n at x star and f
at x star f hat n at x star and x
f at x star and similarly
the variance is just the variance of
this distribution
the variance of f hat n is just the
variance of f hat n
right however um
the the bias variance decomposition
of the squared error loss has a third
component
which is which we call as irreducible
error so
the dotted distribution that is
indicated here
is the distribution of y given x so this
is y given x and it is from this
distribution
that we make the observations y right so
if we were to sample
an example ah from the data generating
process
at x equals x star then the
corresponding y will come from this
distribution
right and the the expected error
that we would make using f hat n
on a new example y star x star can be
ah was written as
so mean square error of
f hat n
is equal to the expectation of
y star minus
f hat n x
star right so we use some training set
constructed our model made a prediction
on
x star and it was a sample from
the thick line distribution right
and it's a random sample because there
is noise in the training set
set that we used if we use the same
training set then we always make the
same prediction obviously
so suppose the the predicted f hat n
was let's say over here
similarly the true label also has some
noise in it
right because it is sampled from the
data generating distribution
and let us say the observed y star was
here so this
is ah y star right
and now this gap is what we are trying
to decompose
from y star to f hat n of x star
right and this can now be broken down
again into three parts
first we ah have spoken about so this
can be broken down into three parts
one part is the gap from the
black square that is like the true
function till y star
right that we call as irreducible error
there is just no way we can
fight that no matter how well we
construct our f hat n
in the observation that we are going to
make that's going to be noise there is
nothing we can do about it
so the expected squared error between y
star
and and our prediction f hat and x star
can be broken down into three parts one
is the irreducible error
the second is the bias and the third is
the variance
right so the irreducible error is
noise in the test data right it's not
noise in the training data irreducible
error component is noise in the test
data
because when we when we deploy the model
there is going to be noise in
in in in the data that we are going to
encounter
the bias and variance are properties of
the training data and the model class
right if the data is noisy and we don't
have a lot of data
then this variance the variance of the
thick line distribution is going to be
large it's going to be more spread out
however if we collect a lot of data
then it this the thick line distribution
the
the the distribution of hatton would be
more concentrated
right but still even even if it is
concentrated there could still be a bias
that is the mean of our our f hat n
and the true value of of f
can still there could still be a bias
and there is a variance because of you
know
the remaining is the variance think of
it as the variance where the variance is
due to the noise and the training data
right so there are three parts
irreducible error due to noise in the
test data variance due to noise in the
training data
and bias right there are three parts and
we also covered regularization
before we go into regularization so
we've just discussed the three
components we still haven't spoken of
any trade-offs between them
but this is the mental model to have you
know in your mind to decompose the
the test error into three parts right
part due to noise in the test data
that's irreducible error
part due to noise in the training data
that's variance and bias
now we also spoke about regularization
and we will see why regularization
plays a role in shortly soon
so regularization is a way in which we
want to
penalize our estimated parameters from
having very large values we want the
estimated theta values to have small
values
and the reason is that the intuition
there is that if you have
large values of of in your theta vector
then your predicted hypothesis can be
very squiggly it can make
very sharp turns and it can sway a lot
and the intuition there is we want to
you know therefore penalize large values
of
of theta and therefore we add an extra
term to our cost function so if j of
theta
which previously used to be x theta
minus
y naught you know this is standard
linear regression cost function and we
will add
an extra lambda times
theta naught
we are going to add this extra
regularization term
into our cost function with the hope
that when we minimize the cost
not only are we trying to fit the data
well but we are also trying to you know
to some extent
make sure that our theta values are not
too large and the balance between the
two
is decided by what is the you know our
regularization coefficient we're going
to use to weight this ah
the regularization term and we also saw
that
the motivation that we we went through
just now it sounds a little
arbitrary sounds a little hacky but in
fact there is
a more principled interpretation to this
from
a bayesian point of view so remember in
ah
in bayesian statistics we construct a
posterior distribution or our parameters
given the data
and what instead of holding on to the
full posterior distribution
to make to construct a posterior
predictive distribution
instead what we could do is just
calculate the mode of the posterior
distribution
and use that mode of the posterior
distribution as the output of our
estimator
and hold on to just that single point
estimate which we call as
theta m a p that's maximum a fourier a
posterior estimate
as our output of the estimator
so the ah we saw how theta hat map
can be written as the arg max of the
product of these two terms
so one is the likelihood term in case of
linear regression the likelihood term
will
will turn out to be exactly equal to
this or rather it's going to be you know
some scalar times this
but effectively ah this corresponds to
the likelihood term
and then there is going to be a
regularizer term
due to the prior we assign on on the
parameters
and if the prior happens to be a
gaussian prior
then this prior will will take on the
form of
a squared error on theta right so that's
another thing you want to keep in your
mind in general and
whenever you assign something ah to be
to have a
gaussian distribution or a gaussian
prior it's going to show up as a squared
error somehow
right because you know in in the
exponent of the gaussian there is you
know a square on the
ah a square term and when you take the
log likelihood the exponent and square
cancel out and you're just going to be
end up with
the log and the exponent cancel out and
you're just going to we end up with the
square term in the
exponent so when we have a gaussian
prior
this corresponds to corresponds to the
regularizer term
and the variance that we assign to the
prior distribution
of the gaussian is directly related to
lambda
right the the the stronger our prior is
then the larger lambda is and in your
homework you know you work out what is
the exact relation between lambda and
the
and the variance uh but that's the uh
that's the idea in uh
in general so it means if if this is
the x-axis are the parameters and this
is 0 that's the origin
and we have a prior distribution over
that is centered around the origin
and we have a likelihood function that
is maximized at the maximum likelihood
estimate
so this is our theta hat mle this is 0
and we are trying now trying to maximize
the product of these two
so the product of these two is this
dotted function
and the way you want to think of it is
since we are multiplying two
two functions any region
where either of the two functions is
close to zero the product will be close
to zero
right so it is going to take its going
to be non-zero
in regions where both the prior and the
likelihood are
are non-zero right and so
assuming this is the product of these
two functions
the the theta hat m a p is the value
that maximizes
this the product of these two right so
this is like the posterior distribution
right it it might not be normalized you
need to
divide it by p of s in this case to
normalize it but
you know this is think of this as the
unnormalized posterior distribution
and the value where the unnormalized
posterior gets maximizes
is the same value at where the
normalized procedure gets maximized
and this is theta hat map and therefore
what we see is
the posterior is going to because it's
it's the product of these two the
posterior is going to
kind of lie between the likelihood and
the prior
right because of the product of the two
functions and therefore the value that
maximizes map
is going to be closer to zero than the
mle and therefore
ah the estimated theta values will be
smaller in value because they are closer
to zero
right so this this was uh this is one
way to kind of think of regularization
using the bayesian framework
and in fact in your homework you also
have another uh question where
instead of assuming p theta to be to be
a gaussian
what happens if it's a laplace
distribution right and and over there
you know the intuition to have there is
again
assume this is theta 1 theta d
the prior of a multivariate or or the
product of independent laplaces
is going to look like this
its a star you know its kind of like a
star shaped function whereas in a
gaussian it is going to be
circles and if if
this is theta hat
m l e so if this is the maximum
likelihood estimate
and let's say these are like the
contour plots of the likelihood now the
product
of and this is the contour plot of the
prior
and you can see that the product of
this function and the product of this
function
will achieve a value or high values
generally along the axis
right and and ah and therefore the value
where
m a p is maximized will will lie along
the axis exactly along the axis
and in high dimensional spaces it it
turns out that this results in
sparse parameters which means most of
the axis
most of the theta i values will be
exactly zero because
it's going to be along the axis because
you get you in order to
to the way you uh the way the prior is
is is um structured is that if you want
to
reach out as far as possible and still
have a high
prior value then you need to go along
the axis
to kind of have high uh to have high
high prior probability but still um
stretch out as far as possible to theta
hat you need to do that along the
um along the axis therefore therefore
applying a laplace prior will result in
in sparse sparse parameters and that's
called
the lasso the lasso estimator and
you you explore this in your homework as
well
any other question before we move on to
today's topics yes questions
then you might be able to impose
trade-off definitions by like
because they are parts of probability
yeah so the question is how how do the
the definitions of
of um the the statistical in
the bias and variance and the
statistical inference relate to bias and
variance in in the prediction setting
the the short answer is that
the f theta uh f theta hat of n is
generally composed
of you know theta hat n right so theta
hat
n is is kind of embedded in this uh
um f hat n and and therefore
you know the bias and various in in in
simple cases
they directly transfer you know um which
we'll go over
we'll go over today but in general the
bias in f hat n
is assuming uh you're using some kind of
a parametric model and not
non-parametric
assuming you're using some kind of
parametric model then the bias in
f hat n is related to
the bias of theta hat n
which is the parameter of f
they are related uh in general no matter
what the parametric uh
family is but it's very hard to come up
with an analytical
relation between the two but in in in
general they are the the
the noise in f hat n in the prediction
is due to the noise in the corresponding
theta
yes questions
plus lambda so the question is
uh how does this translate into this so
yeah so the the uh i mean so this is
exactly what you're showing in your home
where you need to show in your homework
the question is how does the prior
result in this
and when you when you when you're taking
the arg max of this
you know if you instead of the product
of p of theta you
you take the r max of the log of these
two that separates into you know two
additional terms
and this will have a gaussian
distribution you know assuming if it's
gaussian
then the log and the exponent of the
gaussian cancel and the
squared and the prior will end up being
this it's pretty straightforward
yeah so if the prior is not gaussian
this will not be squared error
it could be a different uh so if it's if
you apply a laplace
prior then you will have
just the theta knob or the one norm
instead of the two naught right so the
squared error happens only when you
apply ah
gaussian prior all right so moving on to
today's topics
so today we're going to ah
today we're going to see uh how
bias and variance there is a trade-off
between the two using two
kind of case studies so in one case
study we're going to see the role played
by
regularization to affect uh or or how it
affects
uh bias and and and variance and we're
going to use
the the the case of
l2 regularized
linear regression
right so uh i posted some notes over the
weekend that give out that give the
a detailed derivation of all of all the
the steps that we're going to do today
we will just go to the results and
discuss the intuitions about the results
but you know the step by step
derivations are there
in the notes so in case of
in case of
l 2 regularized linear regression first
we will talk about
the bias and variance in theta in the
theta hat itself so remember
l two regularized uh linear regression
has
the cost function
i equals 1 to n
y i minus
theta transpose x
i square right
plus lambda times
theta square right and
if you if you uh
if you work out the ah maximum
if if you work out uh what the optimal
value of theta is for this case there is
a closed form solution
and the closed form solution will turn
out to be this
theta hat n is equal to
x transpose x plus
lambda i inverse
x transpose y right
and this is very ah you know similar to
the normal ah normal equations that we
derived
except there was no extra lambda i term
in that case so if you remember
the the the normal equation gave had
given us theta hat equals
x transpose x inverse
x transpose y
and back then we had we had spoken or at
least briefly mentioned
that its you know sometimes it is
possible that x transpose x may not be
invertible
right and in the case of
l 2 regularized linear regression what
we see is you know we are adding this
diagonal matrix with lambda as the
diagonal values
to x transpose x right and what does
this
give us so supposing x transpose x
has an eigen decomposition where it is u
sigma 1 square until sigma d
square u transpose so suppose this is
the eigen decomposition of
x transpose x by adding
a lambda parameter to a lambda i to this
matrix
we are essentially just adding lambda to
all the eigen values
right if you remember adding a diagonal
matrix to
adding a diagonal matrix to some some
matrix just increases the eigen values
by that diagonal value right
and this is ah x transpose x plus
lambda i right and now if we invert this
matrix
then we are just inverting the
corresponding eigen values
yes question sorry
how
yeah that's that's you know um
so i'm not going to the details of that
that's a standard linear algebra result
where
if you add a diagonal matrix to another
symmetric matrix then
you're just increasing the eigenvalues
by you know the
the amount by which your the diagonals
are scaled that's a standard linear
algebra result and it's very easy to
show it if you know you can post on
piazza i can reply with the steps
but you know that's you know just take
it as a given for now
yes question
so extra x transpo so you
here are assumed to be you know uh
invertible
where u has the property u u transpose
equals u transpose u equals
i so u transpose is the inverse of u so
that's again
you know that's eigen decomposition
right so um
so now we see that because we are adding
a non-zero value to all the eigen values
all the the inverse will exist
because you know we are not doing a one
over zero anymore
in the original uh x transposing some of
the sigma i squared could have been zero
but now that we've added a small lambda
value this matrix is always invertible
and you always get a unique inverse
and now
theta hat n is now therefore this
theta hat n is so x transpose x plus
lambda i
inverse is now this matrix and we can
now see that
the expectation of theta hat
n is equal to
again i am not going to go over all the
steps but
i'll directly write out the last
equation that we get is equal to
sigma 1 square over
sigma 1 square
plus lambda
sigma d square over sigma d
square plus lambda rest are all zeros
times u transpose of
theta star right
so the question is lambda take on only
positive values necessarily yes
so lambda in case of regularization is
always greater than zero
yeah good question
so ah so the expectation of theta theta
hat
n where theta hat n is the solution of
the l 2
regularized regression linear regression
is this matrix so this
whole thing is a matrix times a vector
right so we can make a few observations
here now
supposing lambda was zero right
this whole matrix reduces to the
identity matrix
right because each of the diagonals
become one along the diagonals
u and u transpose have this property
that uu transposes the identity
so this whole matrix reduces to
a large identity matrix if lambda is 0.
this question how we get this expression
so it is uh pretty pretty
straightforward it's in page four of the
notes
the way you go about doing this is um
so theta hat n is equal to
um we write it over here we write this
as
x transpose x plus
lambda i inverse
x transpose and then in place of y
we write x theta star
plus epsilon right because y
is x theta star plus epsilon as the
assumption and then you
you um you expand this
and you'll get two terms and because of
the epsilon the second term
just becomes zero expectation of epsilon
times the scalar is zero
and the first first expression you apply
eigen decomposition you get this
right the the detail steps are there in
the nodes
but the idea here is that the mean of
theta
theta hat n is this matrix
times theta star so if
lambda is 0 the standard linear
regression
then expected value of theta hat
n is equal to theta star so the linear
regression the standard linear
regression
estimator is unbiased however
if we add a regularization term
then we are multiplying the the
true theta star by a matrix
whose eigenvalues all the eigenvalues
are less than 1
right and if you remember the the eigen
values
decide how much the input space of that
matrix
shrinks or expands in the output space
right so if you feed
some any vector into a matrix
whose entire spectrum whose set of all
eigen values are small
then in the output space is essentially
shrunk
right and so what we see is that the
when when we have lambda greater than 0
the norm of
theta of of uh the norm of this
entire expression is going to be smaller
than the norm of theta star itself
right which is how you see the shrinkage
effect coming into picture
you are multiplying the true value the
true
parameter by matrix whose entire set of
eigen values is less than one
and so the result of multiplying
uh the the vector is going to be a
shrunk version of that vector
right so so that is how we get ah you
know
that's how we see that linear the
the regularization term adds a bias when
theta is non-zero
then when lambda is non-zero then the
expectation is never
exactly equal to theta star
right so that's bias what about the
variance
for reference i'll just continue it down
here so that we can just compare it with
what is above so
so the covariance matrix of
theta hat n
again um you know using a very similar
argument
if if we expand it out we're going to
get that the covariance matrix of
theta hat n will be u
times tau
square sigma 1 square over sigma
square plus
lambda square
tau square sigma d squared
times transpose where
tau is solver
so if taus tau square is the variance of
the noise in
in in our x and y such that
y equals theta star transpose
x plus epsilon so if tau square is the
is the variance
of the error of the error terms
then the covariance of the
theta hat n that is covariance of our
regularized estimate
is this matrix now this matrix
you can observe is symmetric
because ah it's symmetric and it will be
positive definite because all the all
the eigen values are greater than zero
so it is a valid covariance matrix
right just sanity check and what we also
see
is that as we increase the
the uh lambda value to uh
to a larger value then the covariance
matrix
is going to have a smaller spectrum
right the set of all eigen values
of the covariance matrix also reduces as
we increase lambda
because these are the each of these
terms
is just the directly related to
the the um are exactly the eigen values
so if you have a larger lambda then the
eigenvalues of the covariance matrix are
also reducing
which means the intuition to have there
is that your covariance or the variance
in your estimator is also reducing
so if you remember if you have a
gaussian distribution that has some mean
and some covariance
the covariance design the covariance
implicitly defines an ellipse around the
mean
and the smaller the covariance the
shorter
or the tighter the ellipsoid will be
and that's the intuition to have here
the larger the the smaller the
eigen values you have the the tighter
the
the ellipsoid is around around the mean
right so here is one
so so here what we see is as we increase
lambda
the bias in our estimate increases which
is bad
but the variance in our estimator
reduces which is good
right so we want our variance our
estimator to have low variance but we
also want it to have low bias
but what we see here is as we increase
lambda the bias
increases which is bad but variance
decreases which is good similarly if you
reduce lambda
the bias decreases which is good but
variance increases which is bad
right so this this ah
this is one example of you know what is
called the bias variance tradeoff
where some action that we take will
improve one of them either bias or
variance but at the same time
it can hurt the other one this question
so the bias will increase when we
increase lambda
because we are now multiplying the true
value of theta star
through a matrix that shrinks it and
it's it's getting farther and farther
away from the true value
so you know uh we that's that's bad
uh we are going farther away from the
true value itself in expectation
at the same time there is also
you know a variance term involved where
which is our sensitivity to data
right the larger lambda the value of
lambda we have
then the less sensitive we become to the
noise in the training data
and uh and and and that's good so
therefore
lambda is is you know you're kind of by
choosing the value of lambda you're
doing a trade-off between bias and
variance
right and these two terms directly
translate into prediction as well so
this was about
you know about theta hat itself now if
you want to do prediction
if you want to do prediction let us
remember
let us recall the the
the bias various decomposition so mean
squared error of
f hat n we saw was
tao square plus
x star minus
x star whole square plus
variance of
so this is the standard bias variance
decomposition which we
saw last last time as well this is
called the
irreducible error
and this is
y square this is variance
and and this is again in path seven of
your notes the detailed
ah steps of deriving this but let us
just look at look at the result and
and ah try to get some intuition so this
is our bias
and what we see is if if we define
f to be now theta f of x to be
theta star transpose x which is
the the true value of of theta then the
bias
will relate the bias of the predictor
will now relate to bias of
the estimator in this way
so bias of
f hat n of x star
is equal to expectation
of f hat
n x star minus
f of x star
so that is just ah this and this is
equal to the expectation
of theta hat n
transpose x star minus
theta star transpose x star
this is equal to expectation of
theta hat n minus theta star
transpose x star is equal to
bias of theta hat n transpose
x star so the bias in the predictor
is related to the bias in the estimator
with this relation
it's you you just take the transpose of
the bias in the estimator
with the point at predict with the
prediction point prediction input and
that gives you
the bias in the uh predictor yes
question
so the question is can we can we come up
with a closed form expression
for lambda in terms of
sigma and tau
and minimize what so you want the
eigen values to be as big as possible so
that it
stays close to theta but you want the
covariance matrix to be midwives
so you write some sort of like a
relation and then minimize
your value you minimize your variance
and you maximize your eigenvalues
so i guess if i understand you correctly
you're trying to
um you're trying to say is there an
optimal way to
find out kind of the best value of
lambda
or the optimal value of lambda
to simultaneously minimize that and
maximize that we will we'll come to that
shortly so we're going to answer the
question of how to choose lambda
the the close form expression has some
challenges which you know the the with
the method that you suggest but uh
let's let's uh come to that uh shortly
right
so so this is the um so this is the
relation between the bias and the
predictor
and the bias in the estimator where the
relation is defined by the point at
which you are
making a prediction and this kind of a
closed form relation
is possible only for simple models such
as linear regression with
l2 regularization for more complex
models if f hat
n is a neural network then it is very
hard to come up with a simple relation
between the bias
of the predictors of the neural networks
of the parameters of the neural networks
and the prediction that it makes
right but for simple models here we can
we can see the relation between the two
similarly the variance of
f hat n is equal to
x transpose covariance of theta hat n
x so its a quadratic form that uses the
covariance matrix of
theta hat n along with x as the input to
get the variance of
right so so and and and similarly the
the
um and therefore because there is you
know
a straightforward relation between the
bias
from the estimator to the predictor and
the variance from the estimator to the
predictor
the effect of lambda is also the same so
if we increase
lambda to a large value
the variance of the estimator comes down
and the variance of the predictor comes
down and if we
increase reduce lambda then the
bias of the estimator comes down and the
bias of the predictor also comes down
right because it is a very simple
relation between the two now
any questions on this
so in general what we care about is we
want to
minimize the
squared error on future predictions
right in machine learning that's our
goal
right what we want to do is is have
a have an estimator or a predictor that
has very good
load generalization error so
generalization error is how well we
perform
on unseen examples
and for that what we see is in order to
minimize the generalization error
we have three different components that
we can go after right all of them are
nonzero so reducing any one of them
will reduce the overall generalization
error
right and these these three components
as we saw before
is the irreducible error bias the square
of the bias
and variance that add up to form the the
mean squared error
now to reduce any one of these let's
let's see
uh what what happens so irreducible
error is something we
we can we cannot do anything about right
that's just a fact of life we have to
live with the irreducible error
no matter what kind of a predictor that
you come up with you can never do better
than
irreducible error right so that's like
our our
the best we can hope for and then we
have these extra two terms bias and
variance
so if we want to reduce generalization
error then we need to reduce either bias
or variance or both
unfortunately what we saw was
some steps such as regularization
will if we tune the regularization to
reduce the bias it
increases the variance if we tune it to
reduce the variance it increases the
bias
right so that's at that's that's like uh
that's the fundamental tradeoff that we
need to work with to
to find some kind of an optimal optimal
ah minimizer of the sum of these two
terms
right and there was a question that was
asked why not try to analytically
minimize this
and in to to analytically minimize this
we need to be able to compute
f of x star without being able to
compute f of x star we cannot
find the right balance to minimize the
sum of the two
and therefore what we are left with is
to use cross validation
so what we do is take a validation set
we discuss cross validation ah in the
last lecture
have a validation set and and keep that
away when you're fitting your model
once you fit your model with some
specific value of lambda
see how well your the fitted model which
is regularized performs on the cross
validation side
right and then when you measure it on
the cross validation set
you're measuring the overall mean
squared error we we're not we're not
measuring
the individual components when you
measure this the the
error made by the model on the cross
validation set we are measuring the
overall error
right and then we now start tuning
the lambda parameter to different values
increase it a little decrease it a
little
and with the tuned values measure the
performance on the cross validation
error again
and tune it such that the the the
overall
mean squared error on the cross
validation you find some kind of a good
minimum
by doing that process you are
automatically optimizing for the overall
mean squared error
and implicitly finding a trade-off
between bias and variance
right it's very hard to get an exact
breakdown of what was the
irreducible error component what was the
bias component what was the variance
component
but the theory suggests that by tuning
lambda
we're going to have we're going to have
some kind of a trade-off between bias
and variance
and there may be and there probably is
some kind of an optimal
lambda that finds a suitable tradeoff
between the two
and the way we do about where we go
about doing that in practice is using a
cross validation set
where we are directly trying to minimize
the
the overall mean squared error without
actually finding out what the exact
broken down components was
the other
i guess the the larger takeaway from
this is that
even beyond regularization
in machine learning as i said before
what we care about is
reducing the mean squared error right
and if we want to reduce mean squared
error
we want to take some action that either
addresses bias
or addresses variance right and in order
to
to make the judgment of whether we want
to go after bias or go after variance
we need to get some kind of heuristic
estimate of what the current
bias value is and what the current
variance value is right but as i said
already unfortunately it is not possible
to get you know a close form expression
because
f of x star is unknown that's that's
that that's at the heart of the problem
we don't know what f of x
x star is uh if we knew it we could
exactly calculate bias component and
variance component
but ah but but but we don't have access
to f
so instead uh what we do is we fall back
to heuristics
right so the heuristics is that
right so this is a heuristic
that is extremely useful in practice
it is if you change this approximately
equal to equal to
then it's very wrong because the
training error is not your bias
and the cross validation error minus
training error is not the variance
but they are extremely useful heuristics
so
when we are trying to to uh build a
model
that gives us better generalization
error
as i said again our goal is to minimize
generalization error our goal is to
not go after bias or variance by itself
but we do that
you know just in order to minimize the
generalization error
and in order to minimize the
we always want to get a rough sense of
the breakdown between bias and variance
components that are contributing to
the generalization error and a rough
heuristic again
is to consider the training error as the
bias
and the gap between the cross validation
error and the training error as the
variance
okay so when we want to
improve our generalization error we
first need to find out
what's the breakdown and go after the
the component
that is larger we never want to
take an arbitrary step such as you know
get more data or
add more regularization or reduce
regularization there are there are a
whole number of things you can do to
improve
a generalization error but
it would be extremely wrong if you just
tried them arbitrarily right that's
that's probably the biggest takeaway
from this lecture and probably the
biggest takeaway from this course
in machine learning we want to reduce
generalization error and the way you go
about reducing
generalization error is to construct
heuristic estimates
of the components r and the heuristic
estimates are the training error and the
cross validation error
and only once we come up with these
heuristic estimates
we make a conscious decision of whether
in the next step we want to reduce bias
or we want to reduce variance
and the way you go about making that
decision is to see which of these two is
is like the larger evil
is your training error so large and the
gap between your cross validation and
training error is so small
that you you know better go after your
bias first which means
to improve bias
to improve bias or maybe to
fight bias is probably the better term
to fight bias we do things like
make model
larger so if it is a neural network then
add more layers or add more neurons in
each layer reduce
regularization
you know etcetera and
to fight variance
we do things like increase
regularization
or collect more data
right and
and the way you go about improving you
know i'm repeating this again because
this is
you know this is probably at the heart
of this entire lecture that
our goal is to minimize mean squared
error and to minimize mean squared error
in theory there are so many possible
actions that you can take
but before you go about taking any
action you want to come up
with some kind of a heuristic estimate
of what the breakdown is
what is the amount of you know estimate
of the bias
in our in in our generalization and
what's the estimate of variance
and once you get this breakdown
we then make a conscious decision of
whether we want to fight bias or we want
to fight variance
in the next step and in order to fight
that particular
of the two evil we choose one of the
actions
that help us fight that component this
question
yeah yeah absolutely so the question is
do we not consider
uh reducing the flexibility of the model
to fight variance absolutely you know
simpler model
so this this is not an exhaustive lift
these are just some examples
you know simpler model absolutely you
know more complex model
but we know that like f star is a
function of theta star
like our true underlying process is a
and theta star and the expectation of
our estimated thetas
is a function of theta star from that
matrix and we can plot
the different diagonal values as like as
a
very weird kind of curve where we can
take all the diagonal values in the
first matrix and all the diagonal values
in the second matrix
and we can find a huge sort of curve
where if we
keep changing lambda the theoretical
value of those diagonals will keep
changing right
and if we take that bow shaped curve and
find the minimum of that curve
we'll be able to optimize those as well
as this simultaneously
theoretical perspective we don't need to
go after the test
so the question is um uh again i guess
your your uh what you're uh suggesting
is a few ways in which
uh using this analysis we can you know
try to come up with optimal values of of
lambda that minimizes like the sum of
both the errors
right the the uh so
so the first problem with that is such
an analysis is possible only for simple
models
right if you want to increase the the uh
for example if you want to reduce the
bias of your model
you you may want to switch from linear
regression to say a neural network or a
gaussian process right
and once you do that this analysis
breaks down at that point
and and uh this exercise of seeing the
breakdown
is useful to get like an intuition a
mathematical intuition of what's
happening underneath
uh but in order to take some real world
action you want to follow res
you know recipes like this right if you
want to if you if you see that your
model is not fitting
you know your your examples uh your data
well your
to fight bias you could say add more
features right
and once you do that your entire
covariance matrix is no more of use
because it's now a larger covariance
matrix with an extra dimension so it's
it's
the the actions that you take
they are kind of beyond that simple
analysis
so the question is you know are our uh
decisions influenced by
you know theta star right so theta star
is unknown
because if it was known then we wouldn't
even go through this exercise of
taking data and fitting models right and
it is because it is unknown that uh that
we we come up with
this kind of an analysis to see you know
how how how
bias and variance can can impact us
all right ah any questions on this
before we move on to
to ah the next part uniform convergence
right so this one
so what follows next in this lecture is
going to be a
a quick high level
introduction or overview of
statistical learning theory or or like
the general kind of flavor of how
statistical learning theory is
what are like the common what's the
common framework of analysis and
and you know what are the kind of things
we
we can do with statistical learning
theory
and this would be especially interesting
to to those who have an interest to
move into machine learning research but
also the results that we see
will kind of strengthen our intuitions
about bias and variance
so for statistical learning theory so
let's
so we make a ah
so common assumption that that that is
kind of widely made
in statistical learning theory or in in
most theory
is that our training and test data
they come from the same distribution
if this assumption is not there it's
very hard to say anything at all in
general
so the the uh the underlying assumption
that we're going to make
is that our training and test data come
from the same distribution
and our examples are sampled iid
right so this in each example sand is
sampled independently of
any other example that we have and at
test and train time
we are we are working with data that is
coming from the same distribution
and now with these we define the
following terms
so the risk of an estimator
so let us call this distribution as d
risk of an estimator is defined as
let us call it risk of a hypothesis
so the risk of the hypothesis is defined
as the
expectation x comma y
sampled from this distribution
of loss
of y and h of x
right so h over here
is our hypothesis it is a function that
takes as input sum
x and produces y as an output
so the risk associated with this
function
right so this is also called as a risk
functional because it takes as input a
function
and returns as output a real value so
the risk of a hypothesis
is the expected loss
made by that hypothesis under some kind
of a loss
loss function so this is you know
generally accuracy of squared error or
something along that sort where the data
that we are using
to feed as input to x and compare it to
the y are sampled from
the data distribution right so this is
the uh
definition of the risk of the hypothesis
now suppose ah there is a related
term if s
is some set of
x i y i
pairs y equals 1 to n so if s
is some training set then we define the
empirical risk
as epsilon hat
of h is equal to
1 over size of the data set
times sum over x y
in s of
loss y comma
h x right its very similar to the risk
definition except instead of taking a
full expectation over
the entire data generating distribution
we just limit
ourselves to taking an average over the
training set that we that we have
right and this is called empirical risk
now
what we want to do ideally or you know
the best we could hope for is to find
some kind of a hypothesis that minimizes
the risk
that's why what that's what we want to
do that's our
that's that's our desire to min to find
an h that minimizes
the true expected risk but what we
actually do in practice is to find
a hypothesis that minimizes the
empirical risk because we have some
some training data we construct a loss
function over it and we minimize
the empirical risk instead right and
that's what you know
you you we've seen this so many times
you've done it in your homework
linear regression you know we use a
design matrix
we take the labels and use the normal
equations to minimize the empirical risk
right so the questions the question that
that comes into mind
is what's the relation between you know
for uh given
[Music]
h what
is the
relation between epsilon hat
of h and epsilon of h
right how does the training error relate
to
the generalization error for any given
hypothesis like you know that's an
interesting question and
the other question is
how does our
generalization error
compare
to the best possible generalization
error
right so our training error is something
that we can measure the generalization
mirror is something that we cannot
measure
right but we're going to use some theory
to make statements about
or give you bounds on how well our
general what our generalization error
will be
given that our training error is some
value right
similarly what's i guess you know ah
what's what's what's important at the
end of the day is how well is our
generalization performance
compared to the best possible
generalization performance that you can
get
right and here we are comparing two you
know two things both of which we cannot
measure right
we have no idea how well our
generalization error is
and we have no idea what the best
possible generalization error is either
right but we still want to make some
kind of probabilistic statements or give
us bounds
on the gap between the two right if we
know
that our the generalization error of our
model
is within some small range of the best
possible generalization error
then you know we are happy right we may
not be happy with you know happy with
the result itself but we know that we
are we are pretty close to what's
theoretically possible so
in order to kind of get a better
understanding of
each of of these two
let us define you know some terminology
so on the x axis we have the set of all
possible hypotheses
what i mean by set of all possible
hypotheses
and literally means set of all possible
hypotheses like the set of all possible
neural networks the set of all possible
svms set of all possible gaussian
processes set of
all possible models that are not yet
invented today you know every possible
hypothesis
you know comes on the x-axis and we're
going to
linearize it to to make the
visualization simple but you know
imagine
you have all possible hypotheses on on
the x axis
on the y axis you are going to have risk
right now was there a question
what do you mean by that yeah so yeah so
what i mean by hypotheses a set of all
possible predictive models you can you
can think of you know
random forest neural networks everything
you know comes comes on this axis
now on the y axis we have risk
and supposing we we indeed had access to
the true data generating distribution
right hypothetically
we had access to the true data
generating distribution and we could
take an infinite number of samples
right we could take
the entire infinite set of samples from
the distribution
take one of these hypotheses and measure
the empirical measure the the expected
loss
of that hypothesis at the uh
against all the entire infinite set of
examples
and that was gives a point
right so this is the hypothesis that we
feed in over here
and this is the value it evaluates to
the risk
right and similarly we can we can repeat
that for every possible hypothesis
you know across all models and that's
going to give us some kind of
some kind of a risk function
so this is not empirical risk we are
talking about the true risk
you know assume you get the entire
infinite sample and
and you you um evaluate the uh the loss
and you know let's assume this is the
the kind of loss you get you know
this is a risk however
we don't have access to this right we
wish we didn't have access to that and
then we could just minimize it if we had
access to it
but we do not have access to it what we
instead have
is a finite sample s
and from this s we can construct the
empirical risk
and the empirical risk might look
something like this
right its going to be some kind of an
approximation
and this gap between the true risk and
the empirical risk
is intuitively you know you can think of
this gap to be a function of
your data set size right as you get more
and more data set
as this n increases then the empirical
risk
and the true risk they become tighter
and tighter you know the the empirical
risk gets closer to
the true risk now this particular
risk function is specific to one
set one specific set of training set
that we have
if we take another training set of the
same size that might give us a different
risk function right so these you know
think of these two as two examples of
risk functions or loss functions that we
get
from two different training sets both of
the training sets are sampled from the
same data generating distribution
and they have the same size right and if
we keep repeating this again and again
we are going to get
more and more such you know dotted lines
more and more such empirical risks
that are spread about the the true risk
with some variance and if you know you
can imagine that if we
if we increase the data set size then
the spread around the
true risk will be much tighter right we
will formalize that
shortly now
the true risk
right the true risk that's the the thick
line
is minimized at some point
right the gap between you know this
minimal point
and the x axis this gap
is the irreducible error
right no matter what model you get you
know model invented you know
10 years from now no matter what model
you get you can never do better than the
reducible error
because that's just because your data is
noisy yes question
so the question is how do we know that
the irreducible error
is can be reached by you know some model
by definition if you have used
non-parametric models and
you have the model uh you know
h of x equals expectation of
y given x equals x
now a non-parametric model this function
will give you this
right but you may not be able to
approximate this well with
with you know some function but there
exists a function that is going to
minimize your
true risk to the absolute minimum and
that minimum
is the irreducible error right
so this is with the assumption that
we're using the squared class so the
squared loss is minimized by the mean
if you use like the absolute value then
instead of the expectation you take the
median
and so on right but but there is there
exists some some function that's going
to minimize it
right so this is the irreducible error
now however we are going to limit our
analysis
to a class of models
right we are going to limit ourselves to
just say the set of all neural networks
random forests and svms and logistic
regression right
we are going to limit ourselves to a
class of models
right and this class of models that
this interval on the x axis i am going
to call it
script capital h right which is
class of model class of hypotheses
hypothesis right and what we then see is
this class of within this class of
models
the best possible risk that we can hope
for
is found here right so this is the point
within the class of models that
minimizes the risk the most and here i
am talking about
the true risk not the empirical risk
right so let us call this h star
which where h star is best
in class hypothesis
right so this is the best in class
hypothesis and
the difference between the two
this gap is called the approximation
error
right its called the approximation error
because this is the penalty that we
incur
by limiting ourselves to a particular
class of models
right if if we did not limit ourselves
to
you know this class but we used a wider
class
then our western class would have been
the same as the you know irreducible
error but because we are approximating
the hypothesis by some class of
hypotheses
then this is the extra you know the
extra penalty that we are paying due to
limiting ourselves
right that's called the approximation
error
however that the the model that we
say end up using is the one
that we get by minimizing the empirical
error
okay so it is the empirical risk that we
minimize
in order to come up with the model right
now if
this dotted line so let me erase the
other dotted line
too
so in practice what we do is we take a
training set and we get this
as our last function and we minimize
this loss function
and the point where we minimize
we get a hypothesis let us call it h hat
right this is the estimated hypothesis
right so in case of linear regression
this corresponds to the theta hat vector
that we get
right
and now because we
we let me move this a little
to the right so that it's easier to to
visualize
so let's assume this is where we get h
hat
now this is where the the empirical risk
was minimized
and the corresponding
generalization error is over here
right and this gap
is called the excess risk or the
estimation error or the excess risk you
can call it
both of them let us call it excess risk
right so there is one part
that is the irreducible error we cannot
do better than that no matter what
there is another part called the
approximation error
which we it is the penalty that we paid
by limiting ourselves to
a class of hypotheses right
and there's yet another component called
the excess risk
it's also called the estimation error
and this is the penalty that we pay
for having a limited data set a finite
data set rather than the full infinite
number of data right because if we had
the full infinite data then our
empirical risk would be exactly on the
thick line and excess risk would reduce
to zero because we would
just end ah you know finding this as our
empirical risk minimizer
yeah so we want we want to find points
such that the risk is minimized so
going higher up is bad we compare it to
the irreducible error we are actually
doing better than
just going with the optimal value so we
are doing worse than the irreducible
error because irreducible is even lower
yeah but in that class you can either
have h star rich
h is closer to a reducible error than it
started
so so so i wouldn't read too much into
the vertical
into the horizontal distance between
anything uh
what we care about is the error incurred
expected error and curve we want the
error to be minimized so
this this is you know the fact that i
have even drawn it linearly is
is a big you know a simple
simplification so
don't don't read too much into uh the
the horizontal ordering of things
right so so what we want now
ideally is to minimize this excess risk
or at least get a bound on excess risk
right
and the way we go about doing that is we
are going to break it down into
into two sub steps
so
so the way we are going to do it is
first
so step one
i'm going to form
convergence
step two
excess risk bound right so
we're going to follow these two steps
where the second step
is is is very
is a pretty straightforward step and
applies to all models
but the class of model that we use and
the last function that we use
is going to give us different techniques
for doing step one
right so roughly speaking uniform
convergence
means
the intuition behind uniform convergence
is that
we want our risk function the
the empirical risk function to converge
to the true risk function
in a uniform way right and we want to
make to
to come up with some kind of a a
probabilistic bound
on how far apart the empirical risk
function
is from the true risk function right
so if you're if you if you've taken some
you know advanced mathematical classes
before
you might be familiar with the concept
of functions converging to other
functions
and that's exactly what's going to
happen here so this is some function
the empire the the true risk is another
function and now we are going to see
how the empirical risk functions
as we increase the number of data points
we have
will probabilistically converge to the
true risk function
uniformly across all points right that's
that's the the um that's the intuition
to have that we want to minimize the gap
uniformly across all hypotheses
so the uniform convergence statement
the statement looks something like this
so with probability so w
p means with probability so with
probability
greater than equal to 1 minus delta
so delta generally you know you want to
think of delta as like a small value
so if you want to give like a 99
probability statement then delta will be
0.01
if you want to give you know with
probability eighty percent then delta
will be point two right so you think of
delta as the gap between
ah one and the level of probability that
you want to give a statement
so with probability one minus delta
for all h
in h so we're going to limit ourselves
to a particular class of hypotheses
right we are doing our analysis now
in the context of a particular class of
hypothesis
the generalization error epsilon of h
minus
epsilon hat of h
is less than equal to some term gamma
where this gamma
is a term that involves
n delta and
class of hypothesis
right so this is the standard template
of all uniform convergence results
and the result is is is different
for different classes of models for
different loss functions
and so depending on the class of model
that you have
you will obtain you know a different you
will obtain a term for gamma
that that uses these terms in in some
particular way if it if you're using
uh say svms then this term is going to
be different but in general
the term over here is is is going to use
this is going to be a term over n delta
and
the hypotheses and the statement says
with probability 1 minus delta
you know you think of it as with high
probability
for all hypotheses you know for all
hypothesis on the on the x
axis the gap between the
the test error or the generalization
error and the
the gap between the true risk and the
empirical risk for that hypothesis
is less than gamma so it's basically
tell you it's telling you
if you give me a training set size n
the degree of of of a confidence you
want in the statement
and the class of hypothesis then i will
return you
some margin think of gamma as a margin
such that with probability say
99 percent the gap between the true risk
and the empirical and the empirical risk
is going to be less than gamma with
probability 99
which means for say 99 with 99 percent
probability
for any given age the gap between
the true risk and the empirical risk is
less than gamma
for all h right it's
think think about it you know carefully
because it can be a little confusing
what we mean is for any given edge let
us consider this h
right for this h
we have fixed the number of examples n
and we are going to repeat collecting n
examples fitting a model
evaluating the the uh uh empirical risk
repeat uh take a new set of n examples
fit the model by minimizing the
empirical risk and
and plotting the error and that will
give us points like this
so each experiment is going to
give us a point like this and what it
says is for
any given hypothesis for all h
the probability that
the the the point that we get
the empirical risk that we get
and the true risk at that point the gap
between the two let's call it gamma
gamma is going to be the the the gap
between
the gap between the two sorry this is
not gamma this this will be less than
gamma
right so there is going to be some upper
and lower bound plus gamma and minus
gamma
so this is a gap of two gamma so it says
with probability
greater than one minus delta the
empirical risk is going to be within you
know gamma
of the true risk
and how do we go about actually
calculating this this
particular value of gamma is going to
depend on the kind of hypothesis that
you are working with
right and
and we will see a few examples of this
shortly yeah
yes n is the size of the sample and the
intuition you want to have here
is the larger the n you have the smaller
gamma will be which is good
right and the smaller the delta you have
which means the tighter the bound you
have the larger gamma will be so if you
want a high probability bound then gamma
will be bigger
right and the larger the n you have you
know you're reducing the variance
so the so to reduce gamma you want to
either
increase n or even increase
delta which means you want a lower
probability bound
this question
yes this is this is going to be a
template for a theorem
that you can derive different values of
gamma for different model classes
it will be uniform and and we're going
to go more
i'm just giving you a flavor of the the
way the statements will look
and and we will see a few more details
shortly
right right so this this uniform
convergence results will always follow
this flavor
where you are trying to
obtain a probabilistic bound on the
margin
of how far apart the true risk and the
empirical risk will be
and that margin is going to depend on n
delta and
and the hypothesis class itself this
question um
it need not be continuous over help all
possible hypothesis space
so the question was you know is the risk
functional continuous over the
hypothesis space and and
you know the hypothesis space itself
need not be continuous so it's
right so in general yeah so the all
uniform convergence results are going to
look like this where
you you want some kind of a gap between
the empirical risk and the true risk for
any hypothesis you know
this any hypothesis is what is why we
call it uniform convergence
and that gap is going to be you know
less than some
margin gamma for a particular level of
probability
probabilistic confidence and this gamma
will depend on n
the level of confidence and the
hypothesis class
right and assuming we have
derived some gamma in this way
we can then plug it into the excess risk
bond
right excess risk mound
so i am intentionally ah not giving an
example of
a concrete example of this yet lets see
how this plugs into the excess risk
bound and then will see a more concrete
example of this
so the excess risk bound results
looks something like this with
probability
greater than equal to one minus delta
epsilon of h star is less than or equal
to
epsilon epsilon of h hat is less than
equal to epsilon of
h star plus
two gamma right this this looks somewhat
similar to this
but it's it's pretty different so first
of all here
in uniform convergence we are talking
about the same h
but the different risk functions you
know we are talking about the gap
between the
the true risk and the empirical risk
whereas over here
we are talking about the true risk
itself but it's
the difference in the true risk between
our estimated hypothesis
h hat and the best possible hypothesis h
star or the best
best in class hypothesis h star right
and
the only difference between the two is
you know from gamma
we went to two gamma why is that
right and this is this is a pretty ah
pretty cool result you know very kind of
intuitive result yes question
um
yeah so let me let me draw a quick
picture about this so the question is
why does
the excess risk involve h hat i guess
that's what the question was
anyway so
so if this is our region of interest
right and let's say this was
is the true risk and
is the empirical risk so this is epsilon
of
h this is epsilon hat of
h right so
what we want here is so this
is h star that minimizes
that minimizes the true risk and this is
h hat that minimizes the empirical risk
all right so now the excess risk is
this gap this gap is the excess risk
right
so the excess risk
we want to get a we want to get a bound
between two points on the thick line
right
but whereas what uniform the convergence
gives us
is a bound between the dotted line and
the thick line for any given value of h
right that's what uniform convergence
gave us it gave us a bound
on the margin between the thick line and
the dotted line for any given value of h
but instead what we want is a bound on
the gap between
two points on the thick line itself
how do we go from go from this bound
to this bound is i guess the question
for this uh for this proof
so the proof is pretty
pretty nice and intuitive
so epsilon of h hat which is the
generalization error of our learned
hypothesis or the estimated hypothesis
is less than or equal to
epsilon hat of h hat plus gamma
right and this comes directly from the
uniform convergence result we apply the
uniform convergence result
at h hat and it says that the true
risk function cannot be more than
gamma away from the empirical risk at h
hat any questions on this the first step
ok right so this is
uniform convergence at
h hat right and then
we going to say this is less than or
equal to
epsilon hat of h star
plus gamma what changed from here to
here
the empirical risk at h hat
is less than the empirical risk at h
star what does that mean
this is the empirical risk empirical
risk at
h hat is less than empirical risk at h
h star and that is by definition because
h hat
minimize the empirical risk so the the
the the risk at
h star cannot be less than the empirical
risk as h star cannot be less than
the empirical risk at h hat because h
hat by definition minimize the empirical
risk
does it make sense
and now so this is basically uh
by definition
of empirical risk
minimization
right and this in turn is now going to
be
and now we are going to make a statement
that the gap between
let me just write it down so epsilon of
h star plus gamma
now we are going to again apply uniform
convergence for the gap between
the true risk and the empirical risk at
eight star
right uniform convergence tells us that
the gap between these two
these two risk functions is going to be
less than gamma
at any edge with some probability right
so
it's going to be less than h over here
and it's going to be less than h over
here
right so
this is uniform convergence
at h star
so the risk between h hat
epsilon hat of h star and epsilon of h
star
is going to be less than gamma right
it's
epsilon ah here you know we are applying
this at h star
and this is basically equal to epsilon
of
h star plus gamma plus two gamma sorry
right which is the result that we want
h hat is less than epsilon of h star
plus two gamma
so what happened here we had a tool
called uniform convergence that gives us
a gap between the dotted line and
the thick line at any hypothesis h
and using that tool we wanted to
obtain a gap a bound between two points
on the thick line itself
which in general is not possible but we
are going to use the fact that we are
doing
empirical misc minimization so we have
you know one one gap here
and so this is less than gamma
this is less than gamma uniform
convergence tells us this is less than
gamma and this is less than gamma
uniform conversion at two different
points and empirical misc minimization
tells us
this point is less than this point
right so two you know so this this
basically allows us to order this point
to be less than 2 gamma times
this point because this point cannot be
a gamma more than here
this cannot be you know this cannot be
less than here and this cannot be gamma
less than here so at most the gap
between these two is two gamma
right so to to kind of draw it clearly
so this is epsilon hat of h this is
epsilon of h and this is at most gamma
and we have epsilon hat
of h star
which must be more than epsilon hat of h
h hat and this can be at most
this is less than gamma
and this is epsilon of h star
right so this is less than gamma this is
less than gamma and this has to be more
so at most these two can be
less than two gamma
right so once we are able to derive
a uniform convergence bound for
a particular hypothesis class we can
just multiply it by 2
and get an excess risk bound to tell us
how well our model is going to perform
in the real world relative to the best
the best possible model that could have
performed in the real world
right now with this template
let's see any questions on this before
we see a few examples of uniform
conversions
this this is the general recipe you know
of of
we're going to use uniform convergence
to to derive
the the gamma term and that's going to
be different
using different techniques for different
kinds of models
uh and and different kinds of loss
functions but once we get that
uniform convergence bound of of gamma
for a given hypothesis class
you're going to then plug it you know
using this technique
to obtain an excess risk bound which is
just two times gamma
right no questions yes questions
what the statement is saying the
empirical risk
for the so restricting yourself to a
certain hypothesis class
the one that each hat is the one that
you pick
which minimizes the empirical laws
this is not the empirical loss right so
epsilon is not the empirical loss
epsilon hat is the empirical loss
epsilon is the the generalized loss or
the true risk
this is the true risk in the excess risk
bond we are talking about
the true risk at the empirical risk
minimizer
and the true risk at the best in class
hypothesis
right so we are kind of both of these
are
in general not measurable because it's
measuring the true risk at you know
at two different points we calculate h
hat using empirical risk minimization
we have no idea what this value
evaluates to here we have no idea what h
star is and we have no idea what that
evaluates to
but we can still derive an upper bound
on this on this on the gap between the
two using this technique
and in order to kind of actually you
know completely
this technique we need to get you know a
uniform convergence which is a bound on
gamma
at any point of at any hypothesis h
question
so the empirical risk at eight star
should be less than empirical risk at h
hat
so it need not be so that's a good
question so the empirical risk at
eight star and the empirical risk at h h
hat they may be flipped
they may be in any order what uniform
convergence tells us is the absolute
value between the two
is less than gamma so the the uh
what that means is at eight star
the empirical risk may have been you
know above it it's
it's that's totally possible
this question
class you're saying that you take a
neural network with one layer and you
take it with
a thousand years this is always going to
hold so like make it
entire hypothesis yeah so
so so the question is what if we make
hypothesis class like you know
infinite say using neural networks we're
going to come to that uh
that's exactly what we're going to come
to now so any any questions on
on this this technique this question
yeah so h hat is the empirical ros
minimizer which means the empirical loss
at h hat will be less than empirical
less than or equal to empirical loss at
8 star right it says nothing about
the true risk versus empirical risk at
any of those points they may be flipped
uniform convergence tells us that they
cannot be gamma apart so the true risk
may have
may have gone below the empirical risk
also it's you know it's totally possible
all right so ah moving on um
let's see a few results of empirical
risk minimization
i am sorry of a few results of uniform
convergence
so
so case one
finite hypothesis class
so if we assume that we have a finite
number of hypothesis in our class
which is which might seem actually
you know very limiting at at first
but then if you kind of think about it
you know if um
we you know um if you consider logistic
regression
or say a neural network you represent
that
that um you know neural network with
with its parameters stored in the
computer memory
right so the weights of your neural
weights and biases are gets are stored
in your
uh computer um um as as you know some
float values or 64 bit you know per per
parameter or some such representation
and your computer has
finite representation capab capacity so
your each weight
each a parameter is stored as a 64-bit
value
which means it can take at most 2 to the
power of 64 different possible values
right so even though you have a neural
network having real valued parameters
in practice it is actually you know we
are dealing with the finite hypothesis
class just because we are
working with finite capacity computer so
even though this might seem very
limiting at first it's possible to kind
of
use this in pretty powerful ways right
so if if you are considering finite
hypothesis class
where the size of the hypothesis class
is some
value k right
the uniform convergence results tells us
uniform convergence
tells us with probability greater than
equal to 1 minus
delta absolute value of
and for all
h in versus minus
h is less than equal to so the gamma
term that we ah
so the gamma term so that if you
remember in uniform convergence
this is the template that we always
follow and for each different
situation we are going to get a gamma
term that involves n delta and
something about the hypothesis class and
in this case it turns out to be
square root of 1 over
2 n log
2 k over delta
right this question what do you mean
so k here is the size of the uh finite
hypothesis class
yeah as i said you know if you're
storing things in in the computer two to
the power of
you know number of parameters you have
could be used in this case
because you know for each number of
parameter for each parameter
it can only take up to you know a in a
64-bit
uh value so
yeah because you know that is you're
limited to the you know
by the memory capacity in your computer
of you know the different possible
hypothesis you can you can
much more limited yeah in practice it is
which
which doesn't hurt the bound the bound
might be loose but the bound is still
valid
right so you get you get a uniform
convergence result like this
which translates into an excess risk
bound as with
probability greater than equal to one
minus delta
of epsilon of h hat is less than or
equal to
epsilon of h star
plus two times this
one over two n log two k
over delta
right and there are different results
you know for finite hypothesis
class we get a a
margin term in this form for different
kinds of
classes for uh even for infinite
dimensional
infinite size hypothesis class there are
different techniques
where you can obtain terms like this the
key
observation to see here is that this
term
is essentially min
[Music]
h in parts is
h right this is by definition the
performance the
the true risk of the best in class
hypothesis
right and what we see here is now
just like the bias variance analysis we
can do a very similar analysis here
which is what is the optimal size of our
hypothesis class
if we increase the size of our
then this term is going to reduce
because
you're you're searching over a larger
hypothesis space if
if the uh script h is bigger then the
the minimized value will be much smaller
because you are just minimizing it over
a larger space
but if script h is bigger then k is
larger
so this is going to go up because k is
in the numerator
right and this is this is another way of
of kind of
interpreting the bias variance uh
trade-off
where in in the earlier case we saw the
effect of regularization
but here we see the effect of using
bigger classes versus smaller hypothesis
classes
right if you increase your your
hypothesis class to be bigger
then think of this as the bias term and
the bias comes down
but at the same time the variance goes
up because the size of the class appears
in the numerator here
right and you can think of this as the
the mean squared error of your
of your hypothesis where you're testing
it against
you know the generalized performance so
the generalized performance is bounded
by some term
which is like the bias plus some term
that which is like the variance
and here we see the trade-off between
the the hypothesis between having a
larger hypothesis versus smaller
hypothesis because you know the larger
hypothesis reduces one component but
increases the other component and vice
versa
there is in the notes there is another
uh there's another section on how to
work with infinite classes
uh where h is infinite using something
called vc dimensions
and you're you're welcome to read that
we won't test you on the exam
on any of that in fact we probably won't
test you on any of these
uh except the the main takeaway over
here
is that you you you know
it's it's very important that you
understand this trade-off between bias
and variance what we care at the end of
the day
is minimizing generalization performance
or improving our generalization
performance or minimizing the
generalization error
and that generalization error always has
two components a bias component and a
variance component
it's very hard to break them down
analytically
but there are heuristics where we can
consider the bias as the training error
and the gap between cross validation and
and training error as the
variance and always
always when you want to take some action
to improve your models generalization
performance
characterize these two using those
heuristics and
purposefully attack one of them at a
time either go after buyers bias
one at a time or go after variance at a
time depending on which of the two is
bigger
right and that becomes an iterative
process where you
improve one and then you see that you
know that is no longer you know say bias
is no longer the biggest error then you
go after variance
and also uh you know using these
trade-offs you see when
once you when when you fight bias in
some way you know that can increase the
variance and so on
right that's that's probably the the
larger message from today's lecture and
that's probably the biggest
takeaway from the course itself of
dealing with bias and variance
to improve your generalization
performance right let's break for today